the bearing of a white house from a boat
is 310 degrees true
. pause i have a look at the diagram
they give you some letters you would
hope that most of them have been
helpfully names but you don't
necessarily know what any of them mean
the question says the bearing of a
lighthouse from a boat is 310 degrees
and then they provide you this 310
degrees that means if you're measuring
from the boat that's where your angle
should be that's where your compass
belongs okay so that means this must be
where the book starts and that's why
they call this l for white house so I'm
gonna go ahead and I'm actually gonna
label it so so I know what's what and
you can see as well and you'll see more
as I continue through this question how
valuable it is to have a diagram that's
probably comically large so that I can
see what's going on keep reading with me
after the boat has traveled 1200 meters
due west
pause have a look at the diagram every
time you take a little nugget of
information look back at the diagram and
see if we do one of them they're talking
about if you're gonna treat to the end
you'll have too much stuff in your head
you'd be like whoa what's anything
talking about the bridge paltrow under
me is due west where is that on the
diagram it's from A to B right so the
boats Nadya
now Sophia and then they take another
bearing the bearing of the lighthouse
now is 328 degrees true
the diagram shows us information good so
we have a rough idea of what's going on
what are they asking us first it says
find a BL 8b oh all right have a look at
the diagram with me and I really hope to
be able to draw in here right a B L
that's this obtuse angle here in the
bottom left hand corner do you see that
there's a BL in there so if I get marked
I do
and cool that day you know my first job
is to find out what the size of that
angle is now have a look at it can you
see that red line goes straight through
a BL and cuts it into two pieces what is
that red line it's the North line right
now I've got a whole bunch of North
lines there okay
the North lines are important because
every time a North line meets an
east-west line you get a right angle
very good so that means I can say all
right I know one part of a male this
part over here that's already so far so
good if I like the rest of a BL I just
need that little spot in there okay to
have a look can you see what I need to
do to find that tiny little yeah
fantastic you can see if I started from
North and went all the way back round I
get to 360 but if you only go to 328 you
end up here so therefore what's the
extra bit I think that must be 32
degrees so therefore I could say well
there's the 32 degrees which is little
and then there's the ninety degrees
which is just the right angle you worked
out earlier does that make sense so I'm
going to say what was it sparked a angle
a B L I include my working twenty-two it
okay I happy yeah so nothing too fancy
you can see if you've drawn a diagram
well you don't need to pick it up
usually get to Cyril or cosine oh yes
the anglers themselves will give you
enough information
yeah good question so I'm looking
carefully at what they're asking me for
and your ABL and where it is and I see
that the juice angle is made up of move
is the right angle part and then there's
the extra right so there's the right
angle and there's the extra I found out
okay next part says use the sine rule to
find the distance from the boat to the
lighthouse from the boat to the
lighthouse okay where is that it has a
name have a look at DNA it's L do you
see that because because that's where I
used to be but now I'm over here
okay so B L is what I'm looking for if
you want you could label this X if your
life but since it already has a name BL
you're gonna give it another leg name we
can plug that so now think you've still
got your table there which is handy on a
page back rub mine off I'm trying to
find B out and they had actually told me
nicely very conveniently to use the
Simon right so I'm going to have to go
BL on science P equals and then I'll
meet some other side and some other
angle do you agree because I'm gonna
have to use the sign all right have a
look at that triangle
okay very good
I've been given this lengthy in fact
it's the only link I have so I'm gonna
have to use that there's another length
well what's sorry not what sign what
angle is opposite maybe have a look it's
got a name angle
like eh I'll be do you agree nothing
saying no like this is a couple of
angles up there I choose more than a
couple angles up there
so that's why I named it with the
lizard's so I'm gonna go sign a big yeah
okay
now lastly BL BL I need to know what
angle is opposite bill in order to use
Simon what's the name of that angle well
carefully
here's BL it's been don't really
contractile Vincent's use the ambulance
officer is roofer in this corner isn't
it do you see the triangle I'm in and
you see how I'm looking across to the
other side so therefore the number is we
may L do you agree you see that there so
I'm gonna make that sign would be now
they told me to use this time rule I
have written down the sign room with all
of the bits and pieces I know but I also
have bits and pieces I don't know okay
so how am I gonna find out these guys
let's start with B a L that's all that's
missing here okay so how carefully right
if I do yeah okay now aren't you gonna
before we leave that idea 360 minus 3/10
is on my diagram it's not the angle I
want there where is 360 minus three two
yeah it's to get all the way to a full
revolution so go around that would be
the 360 but if you pedal back that will
be well 360 take away 3 days 50 isn't it
so if this is 50 then this must be 40
because again there's more right anguish
by the way I could have gone there
directly instead of going 360 mm rewind
okay I can say if I go all the way
around 3/4 how far it's 3/4 that's 270
isn't it right and then if you go a
little bit further to get to 310 270
going up to 310 that's 40 degrees again
it's the same answer okay so that game
there is 40 degrees do you see how
important it is to have it be diagram so
you can put stuff on it and don't get
too cramped really okay so I just worked
out sign I just wake up being L so I'm
gonna buy that in B now on sine 40
degrees that's equal to 1200 gone I
can't got his tottering where is it
Hey oh babe that's this one up here how
many oh wait this guy
yeah fantastic so I worked at a party
what this think of is I just worked out
what this angle is and that's the third
last one let's see Q we said that this
was a hundred and twenty-two if you add
that that's a hundred and sixty two so
what's that gonna be
eighteen threes I think and if you don't
know obviously you can you can help me
with that so now I know the size so I'm
going to stay tuned there we go that was
a lot of hard work we have a look at
this diagram we have to constantly go
back and forth but now I've got the
information I need so I can just make it
BL the subject how'd I do that again I'm
going to multiply across the sign for T
so that'll give you is and now my
calculator is going to take over okay
can I get a decimal one decimal point me
one decimal point
okay cool
sex Jack a good number does it look
reasonable yeah I think thoughtless yeah
it does and in fact we can do that
superpower and 10 check that I talked
about because I can actually use this
sign real thing be on the side I'm after
right juicy its opposite 40 degrees
what was the other side I used in this
triangle this is compatriot yeah is that
opposite of smaller a bit more a bigger
angle that's it's offered a small
opposite a smaller angle opposite 18
degrees so the inside its opposite 40
degrees you ought to expect it larger
which it is what's the final question
find the distance the boat needs to
travel to be due south of the lighthouse
distance mi trying to fine okay
yes it's very inconvenient good boy guys
someone within to proofread about anyhow
this is high time trying to find daddy
are gonna color this video why not
I bought this this leg many young okay
SD how am I gonna do it what was the
information I just found out by the way
like you saw and use putty to wake up I
want to find out this angle in here why
is that you spoke to me it is really
useful to find out this egg I'm going to
color it fully now why is it handy to me
yeah I'm trying to get into this
triangle did you see that pretty much
all the stuff I noticed over in this
triangle I just found out that this is
two four nine and six point one over
here that's good what I need to get into
this triangle you can see another way of
doing this pretty sure that's 58 right
do you see where I got 58 from if I go
all the way around to here that's 270
right you see I went three-quarters the
way around the compass but then to go a
bit further to get to 328 270 plus 58
and get me there
do you agree with that so that's how I
got that angle in the corner what I do
then
yeah very good you can see in this
triangle over here are being SL it's my
angle yeah so I'm just going to use this
space here cos 58 is adjacent on what
this hypotenuse do you agree so it's s
be on is two for 96.1 amok and now I
just need to multiply across s be
I don't really worry about what the
number is you can check it out if you
like but that was the path that we took
to get there